apple's new iphone 14 pro has sparked a
bunch of controversy in the tech space
in terms of the android versus apple
battle for supremacy with companies like
zte trolling apple's new dynamic island
feature but it's actually samsung who's
really pushing it with the most direct
trolling i've ever seen flexing all over
the iphone 14 pro for not going far
enough but honestly it feels more like
an act of desperation since the iphone
has just overtaken android in terms of
market share now accounting for more
than 50
of the us market and that's before the
launch of the iphone 14. so in this
video i'm going to explain how the 14
pro is going to make things even worse
for android and samsung who desperately
want you to join the flip side but apple
has other plans for the 14 pro now one
could argue that apple is constantly
late in terms of getting major features
like for example wireless charging and
getting rid of the notch but i'm gonna
argue that when apple does it they do it
right apple's mac safe wireless charging
feature is arguably the best
implementation ever created not only
being useful for wireless charging your
iphone while being able to use it thanks
to the magnets but also for use with
tons of accessories like my favorite mac
safe wallet stand from moft now while i
can admit that it took apple way too
long to give us the always on display on
the iphone 14 pro they outdid themselves
by making it better than any other
implementation out there and if you
don't believe me let me explain why
first of all apple is the first company
to allow your actual wallpaper to remain
faintly visible all the time which
hasn't been done before because it would
drain the life out of every android
phone out there but apple is doing
things differently they're allowing the
display to clock down to only one hertz
refresh rate or essentially only
updating the content on the display once
every second using the least amount of
battery life possible even turning it
off when you leave the room with an
apple watch but on the android side even
the samsung galaxy s22 ultra has been
confirmed to only go down to 24 hertz
even and always on display mode so even
though apple was late to the always on
race they already came out ahead now
apple was also arguably late to get rid
of the notch finally replacing it with a
pill-shaped cutout which some are still
calling a notch but what apple has done
with the software is so genius that
android users are already trying to
create third-party apps to copy apple's
new dynamic island feature which is sure
to get some of them to convert over to
the apple ecosystem now if you're an
android user that has finally decided to
switch over to the iphone 14 you're
probably wondering how you can transfer
all of your data well that's where our
sponsor wondershares mobile trans comes
in which lets you transfer your entire
android phone's data over to your new
iphone without any data loss and all you
have to do is connect both phones to
your computer like this macbook then
open up the mobile trans app which also
has cool features like backup and
restore but you'll be choosing phone
transfer make sure the android is set as
the source and the iphone is the
destination and click start everything
should now be transferring and after
just a little bit
that's it you're done and they're
actually doing an iphone 14 giveaway
until october 7th and to win just leave
a comment with your most surprising old
picture after transferring to your new
phone and the best part is that
mobiletrans is giving you guys up to 50
off using our link below so go ahead and
click the link in the description or pin
comment to get started with mobiletrans
today getting back to apple's dynamic
island it basically combines apple's new
pill shaped cutout with software
allowing it to transform into various ui
elements that you can interact with as
well as giving you important information
that can stay on the display at all
times without bothering the rest of your
content it's really an ingenious way to
turn something many iphone users thought
would be a disadvantage into one of the
most unique features we've ever seen and
it's already getting many ios software
developers excited about it since apple
made their dynamic island api public and
even better the dynamic island features
apple's camera and microphone privacy
indicators letting people know that
something is currently recording or
using them which is the cherry on top of
apple's push for privacy like when they
added the do not track while browsing
feature which killed facebook's ad
business and that's something that
android phones simply can't offer on top
of that apple's new ios 16 software just
launched with various features including
the new fully customizable lock screen
with added widgets and even google the
owners of android are already previewing
ios 16 lock screen widgets for their own
apps since they know how important
they're going to be now just like
dynamic island another thing you can't
get on any android phone right now is
the iphone 14's brand new emergency sos
via satellite feature which will
essentially allow you to send a text
message or contact emergency services
anywhere in the world without the need
for a cellular connection and it's now
being reported that this feature is
going to be very hard for rivals to copy
because apple has essentially made an
exclusivity deal with global star in
terms of using their satellites and
spacex's satellite feature isn't
launching until late next year and it'll
be exclusive to t-mobile only so the
iphone 14 pro is currently the only way
to go for a service like this on top of
that apple just unveiled their new car
crash detection feature another one that
you can't get on any other phone which
uses a bunch of sensors to detect when
you've been in a car accident and then
automatically contact emergency services
with precise location data if you don't
respond to the notification which will
literally save countless lives in
situations where someone goes
unconscious after a car crash and that's
part of the reason why apple destroys
android they keep coming out with
features that literally save lives
particularly with the apple watch which
of course requires an iphone but it's
not just those reasons because apple has
been beating android phones in terms of
hardware specs for years now like the
iphone 14 pro's new display which can go
up to a massive 2 000 nits when outdoors
in sunlight beating out samsung's
flagship s22 ultra which can hit a lower
peak of a thousand seven hundred and
fifty nits not only that but benchmarks
for the new a16 ship have leaked and it
looks like it's 17 faster than the a15
in terms of multi-core performance
hitting
5455 points further increasing its lead
over the android competition which tops
out at around 4 300 points and that's
not even mentioning the single core
performance which is now around 44
faster than the best an android phone
can offer and in terms of the camera
performance apple is claiming that their
low light performance is improving by up
to two times on every camera and even
three times on the ultra wide which is
kind of nuts since the iphone 13 pro max
was already competing well in terms of
low light and they finally upgraded
their main camera to a 48 megapixel
sensor so it should offer a lot more
detail while using pro raw mode as well
as the regular photo mode with the new
two times photo option now of course we
won't know for sure until we actually
test out the cameras for ourselves so
subscribe for those upcoming unbiased
camera comparison videos but by far the
most impressive thing about the iphone
14 pro is the price point it's still the
same 999 dollars that apple's flagship
has been since the iphone 10 five years
ago despite the ongoing inflation and in
my personal opinion the new dynamic
island and best in class always on
display features are gonna make a heck
of a lot of people upgrade to the iphone
14 pro but if you disagree with me let
me know down in the comment section
below and if you enjoyed the video click
that circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two videos right there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]